Bert Trautmann was born October 22, 1923 in
Bremen, Germany.
Blue-eyed and blond haired, Trautmann was
the product of a tumultuous political climate
within the post-World War I country.
He grew up surrounded by Nazi-ideology, including
blaming the Jews for the country’s economic
problems and believing certain Germans, such
as himself, were members of the “master
race.”
So it’s not surprising that he joined what
would become the “Hitler Youth” when he
was ten years old.
He later said of this, “At that age you
just want adventure.
It was just like the boy scouts.
It was fun – sport, sport, sport.
The idea that we were Nazis at the time is
nonsense.
The indoctrination came later.”
And, indoctrinated he was.
Although you didn’t know it, your mind was
influenced by the Nazi propaganda.
You listened to the political speeches.
I would be lying if I said I wasn’t impressed.
People have an affinity towards their own
and the Nazi’s were telling us that German
people were suffering apparent atrocities
in Poland or wherever.
We didn’t realise the power of propaganda…
Hitler seized his chance in a country in turmoil.
He said: ‘If you vote for me I’ll get
you this and I’ll do that’.
People had no idea that he was preparing himself
for war and to occupy Europe.
They just wanted food and prospects for their
families.
When the war broke, he eagerly volunteered
for the Germany army.
Most of my friends did too, we didn’t think
why or for what.
Hitler had influenced the education system
to such an extent that we didn’t form opinions.
We were indoctrinated.
There was peer pressure to join the Hitler
Youth and then the forces proper…
People say ‘why?’, but when you are a
young boy war seems like an adventure.
Then, when you’re involved in fighting it’s
very different, you see all the horrible things
that happen, the death, the bodies, the scariness.
You can’t control yourself.
Your whole body is shaking and you’re making
a mess in your pants.
While he initially underwent training to become
a radio operator, he proved less than adept
at the tasks involved and switched gears to
become a paratrooper instead.
As such, Trautmann, only a month out of paratrooper
training, joined other German soldiers in
invading Russia in June of 1941.
He later stated, “We just followed orders,
we didn’t know that Moscow was the ultimate
target and we seldom had face-to-face contact
with the enemy.
You could hear the guns but you never saw
people die.”
However, that October marked the eighteen
year old’s first experience with the brutality
of Hitler’s ideology, and the experience
left a mark on him.
Trautmann and another soldier set out to investigate
gunshots heard in a nearby forest when they
stumbled upon a mass execution conducted by
the notorious Einsatzgruppen, also known as
the SS.
It was hard to take in.
There were trenches dug in the ground about
three metres deep and fifty metres long, and
people were being herded into them and ordered
to lie face down, men, women and children.
Einsatzgruppen officers stood above, legs
astride, shouting; a firing squad was lined
up at the edge of the trenches, shooting into
them.
For a while everything went quiet, then another
group was ordered forward and the firing squad
shot another salvo into the trench…
After witnessing this, the pair very carefully
crawled away from the site.
Had they been discovered by the SS, they would
have wound up in the trench too.
After spending nearly three years on the Eastern
front, including being captured by the Russians
and later escaping, Trautmann’s regiment
was moved west.
At this point, he was among about 100 soldiers
left in his regiment which was 6,000 strong
when it entered Russia.
Then in March of 1945, he decided that he
had enough.
Nearly everyone in his unit was dead anyway,
so he deserted from the German army.
This was no small decision.
He stated later, “I realised that war wasn’t
good.
You couldn’t desert though because the SS
would pick you up if you strayed too far.
They would shoot you or send you to the front
with the youngest soldiers.”
Nevertheless, with no papers granting leave,
he decided to risk it and head for his home
in Bremen, attempting to avoid soldiers from
both sides of the fight.
“I wandered through fields until night fell.
I found myself close to a village.
It was unerringly quiet.
Something didn’t quite seem right and I
went into a farmhouse for shelter.
From nowhere, Americans jumped on me.”
They soon made him turn around with his arms
above his head.
“Then I heard their guns click.
They were about to shoot me.”
But they didn’t.
“I’ve no idea why, but the officer just
told me to clear off.
So I did.
I ran and ran, over hedges and through fields…I
ran straight into six camouflaged British
soldiers.
They were less forgiving.”
The young soldier who had been awarded five
medals, one of which was the Iron Cross (and
all of which he would later toss in the garbage),
for his acts during the fighting was shipped
to England to the POW camp at Kempton racecourse,
and then transferred to Camp 180 in Northwich,
Cheshire.
However, a problem arose in the camp, not
so much from the POW’s towards their captors,
or vice-versa, but rather between the Germans.
Many of the captured POWs were ardent anti-Nazis,
while others were Nazi to the core, and then
there were those in-between.
Needless to say, these groups didn’t get
along well and things came to blows regularly.
Thus, the British had to divide them up, separating
them based on political opinion.
The groups were, Group A: anti-Nazis; Groups
B: those who were more or less politically
neutral; and Group C: those who were thoroughly
indoctrinated with Nazi ideologies.
Having been raised on Nazi propaganda, despite
being somewhat disillusioned at this point,
Trautmann still held to these ideologies and
was placed in Group C. He later stated, “When
people ask me about life, I say my education
began when I got to England.
I learnt about humanity, tolerance and forgiveness.”
His reeducation began by being forced to watch
a film about the Holocaust and learning of
the concentration camps.
“My first thought was: ‘How can my countrymen
do things like that?'”
He was then made to work as a driver for a
Jewish officer, Sergeant Hermann Bloch, to
which he, “quickly came to see Bloch, and
every other Jew, as human beings.
At first I sometimes lost my temper with him,
but, in time, I talked to him as if he was
just another English soldier.
I liked him.”
At the same time he was learning to let go
of Nazi ideology, he also played soccer in
his free time, a hobby he had since childhood
where he’d once been given a certificate
of athletic excellence signed by the president
himself.
The twenty-two year old quickly became a star
on the field at the camp.
He played as a centre-half until his teammates
convinced him to switch to goalkeeper after
he suffered an injury.
After being released from the POW camp in
1948, Trautmann decided against returning
to Germany, instead remaining in Great Britain,
working for the government disposing bombs.
He also continued to play goalkeeper on the
semi-professional St. Helens Town team.
Word quickly spread of his talent, and the
professional soccer team of Manchester City
Football Club offered him a position in 1949.
But having a former highly decorated German
soldier on the team didn’t sit well with
the public so soon after the war, particularly
among the Jewish populace.
A crowd of more than 20,000 people protested
outside of the stadium and letters arrived
that derided the team for signing a former
member of the Luftwaffe.
However, Manchester’s Communal Rabbi, Dr.
Alexander Altman, wrote a letter which was
published in the Manchester Evening Chronicle
arguing against such blanket hate against
the country’s former enemies.
He stated, “Despite the terrible cruelties
we suffered at the hands of the Germans, we
would not try to punish an individual German,
who is unconnected with these crimes, out
of hatred.
If this footballer is a decent fellow, I would
say there is no harm in it.
Each case must be judged on its own merits…”
As Trautmann’s conduct at the time was exemplary,
he eventually won over the fans.
“Thanks to Altmann, after a month it was
all forgotten…
Later, I went into the Jewish community and
tried to explain things.
I tried to give them an understanding of the
situation for people in Germany in the 1930s
and their bad circumstances…”
Of course, it helped that he was exceptional
at his position.
For instance, in his first match in London,
he was initially booed and called all manner
of names by the crowd.
However, after making several truly outstanding
saves during the match, at the end of the
game he received a standing ovation, even
from the opposing team who applauded him along
with the crowd as he walked off the pitch.
He went on to play in over 500 games for the
organization over the next fifteen years and
is generally considered one of the greatest
goalkeepers in the history of the sport, and
the first of that position to ever win the
FWA Footballer of the Year Award, which he
accomplished in 1956- the same year perhaps
the most well-remembered event of his career
took place.
The incident in question took place on May
5, 1956, during the FA Cup Final between Manchester
City and Birmingham City.
In the second half of the game, the score
stood 3-1 Manchester City.
Trautmann was guarding the goal when an opposing
player, Peter Murphy, attempted to score.
Trautmann dove for the ball and ended up with
Murphy’s knee connecting behind his ear.
The immediate result was simply that he saw
stars and experienced significant pain in
his head and neck.
But due to a rule at the time that did not
allow players to be substituted, he continued
to play the last sixteen minutes of the game
“in a kind of fog.”
Despite this “fog,” he managed to make
several critical saves in the last minutes
of the match, saving the game for Manchester
City.
During the medal ceremony after the game,
Prince Philip noted to Trautmann that his
neck looked crooked, but Trautmann gave little
thought to the matter and even attended the
banquet after, despite the pain in his neck
and that he couldn’t turn his head.
The next day, he did go to see a physician,
who told him it was nothing to worry about,
and just a crick in his neck that would resolve
itself in time.
But the pain continued and was so severe that
three days later he decided to get a second
opinion.
That’s when an X-ray revealed that he had
five dislocated vertebrae, one of which had
completely cracked in two.
The only reason he had avoided being paralyzed
and possibly killed after the initial kick
and as he dove around later in the game was
that one of the other dislocated vertebrae
had wedged itself tightly against the broken
one, preventing the two broken pieces from
moving.
Trautmann continued to play after healing
from the injury, finally retiring as a player
in 1964.
Among other awards he received in his lifetime,
the significant role he played in normalizing
British and German relations after World War
II led to Queen Elizabeth II appointing him
an “Honorary Officer of the Order of the
British Empire” in 2005.
He died eight years later at the age of 89
at his home
in Spain.